في تطورات الميدانيه دخلت المواجهات بين
الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع اسبوعها الرابع
ففي العاصمه حلقت الطائرات الحربيه في
اجزاء واسعه من وسط الخرطوم والخرطوم بحري
كما دوه انفجارات عنيفه في محيط القصر
الرئاسي وحي الوابورات بالخرطوم في حين
سمعت اصواته اسلحه ثقيله صباح اليوم
تزامنا مع تصاعدي اعمده الدخان في مواقع
مختلفه جنوب الخرطوم بحري وفي جنوب مدينه
الاوبيض ادت اشتباكات بين قوه عسكريه تتبع
لدعم السريع واحدى المكونات الاجتماعيه
الى مقتل ثمانيه اشخاص وجرح اخرين
واشارت مصادر الجزيره ان اسباب الاقتتال
ذات طابع قبلي
واخيرا قدرت نقابه اطباء السودان عدد
ضحايا الاشتباكات المدنيين باربعمائه
وتسعه وسبعين قتيلا واكثر من 2500 مصاب